So what made me decide to be a general practice nurse
rather than a hospital based nurse?
So I knew from quite early on that I wanted to be a GPN
and work in primary care and
and my placements
Duran University
were mainly hospital based
and the experience that I had on those
and just solidified my decision really
of wanting to be a GPN.
And the main thing for me
is the continuity of care in general practice.
So you build a rapport with your patients,
you see them on a regular basis
and you get to identify their needs
over a long period of time
and you're watching them grow.
So you see them from um,
babies, giving them their primary vaccines
throughout their life
and you watch them grow,
manage their long term conditions, um,
watch them have their own children
and manage their children.
In general practice nursing
you also gain a large range of skills um,
so from vaccinating,
cervical psychology,
managing long term conditions, wound care,
phlebotomy, etcetera.
And you're always learning on the job
and primary care is always changing
so you have to learn and adapt and to the changes
and keep up to date
and go on to do prescribing,
become a nurse practitioner,
advanced nurse practitioner in the future.
So there is a ladder to climb
in general practice as well.
They also prefer that
I'm able to manage my own caseload um
and have that sense of independence.
By running my own clinics
while still working alongside a multidiscipline routine,
gaining advice or help from the GPS
if I need it.
How is that also more sociable in general practice?
So, for example,
you don't do night shifts?
Uh, the salary isn't too bad, either.
Um, I hope that answers your question.